so to illustrate like this this process
of trying to understand you know what's
the universe made all I required an
incredible and a scientific you know
energy and ingenuity and lots of
instruments in fact you know we had to
build a huge the Large Hadron Collider
which is not to object at your to be
able to understand you know what support
underneath you collide all of these
things together and work out the bits
and that kind of thing how do
mathematicians go through working yarn
like the different kinds of objects that
exist in our universe and to help me
understand that
I want you to look back at those four
equations that I asked you to write it
down do you have in there I asked you at
the beginning of the lesson to solve
those four equations and I think they
were these right so consider now maybe
when you looked at these you thought
hung these are a bit random like and
also simple eye focuses extension to you
okay but these are not just random
they're actually very specifically
arranged because what they represent is
a progression they represent in the same
way that are you know going from earth
water wind 500 ah to this to this two
strings in the same way that we
progressed in our understanding of the
material universe the solutions to these
equations represent our progress in
understanding mathematical universe now
I'm going to introduce some language
here for you to help you understand each
of these has a solution and each
solution gets us further closer to the
bottom of what really exists in the
universe right so let's begin with this
one okay the odds are the solutions is
you going to use three okay now three is
what we call a natural number here's the
symbol for it it's an end with some
funky extra lines in it all mathematics
throughout human history everywhere
geographically always starts with the
natural numbers these are the numbers
come with 1 2 3 4 5 etc 3 is a natural
number but quite quickly
stay with the natural numbers and using
just the simple operations you get more
than just the natural numbers right you
discover there's more going on for
instance the solution to this equation
is not an actual number it's not a
number you can cut the solution is
negative two this is what we call an
integer now you're like natural numbers
and financial what's this is a German
word it's the words al s Z a h L and it
means counting someone's own element
these are the integers which include not
just positive numbers but negative
numbers as well now that's weird
but using the tools of natural numbers
and just plus minus times divide you
discover that these things exist just
like scientists discovered these things
exist now keep going have a look at the
next equation the next equation has a
solution that is not natural and it's
not an integer
even the answer of course is a half and
a half is what we call the technical
term is a rational number
now again confusingly the simple form
rational numbers is not an art it's a Q
and Q of course in relationship this is
gonna be a fraction right the Q word
that's where the fractions is quotient
right it's a question so the rational
numbers this is all of the fractions and
the decimals that are either terminating
or recurring these are kind of like
we're getting further we understand is
more kinds of numbers that exist now
then when you get to this guy this
equation is even more special because it
doesn't just have one solution it's got
two but both of the solutions
break the patterns we've already set up
the solutions to this are plus or minus
positive a negative root five right
well root five definitely don't natural
number it's not like one two three four
five six seven root five okay it's
settling on integer or rational it's
irrational right now to say something is
not rational we put a on a [ __ ] line
a curved line over over the Q which
indicates rational
so that means irrational now these are
all of the numbers basically
that like they're almost big families of
numbers with one exception that you guys
know about okay all of these are under
one big umbrella which we call the real
numbers the real numbers now you can do
a lot of maths with the real numbers in
fact all the maths you've done over the
last 12 years has been working with
these numbers right but but just like
with these guys this kind of evidence to
suggest that there's more going on if
there's something underneath here is
something lower down okay
so to illustrate that I want to draw
your attention to not just these four
equations but I also asked you I gave
you two quadratic equations and at last
you to find the sum and product of the
roots the sum and the product of roots
okay now I think the first the first
quadratic I gave was x squared plus 5x
plus 6 equals 0 and you should have
found that for this quadratic the summer
fruit is negative 5 and the product of
roots was 6
okay now this is unsurprising which is
unsurprising because x squared plus 5x
plus 6
it's pretty simple quadratic right you
can factorize it very easily it's X plus
2 X plus 3 which means that the
solutions the roots that the alpha and
the beat on are going to be negative 2
and negative 3 negative 2 negative 3
well that makes sense you add negative 2
negative 3 you'll get this you multiply
negative 2 negative 3 you get this okay
so that's fine but I gave you another
quadratic right I gave you another
quadratic I gave you this guy x squared
plus 2x plus 4 equals 0 okay now just
like before
you can work out you can use - beyond 8
here and that gives you excuse me gives
you negative 2 and then you use C on a
to get a product that gives you 4 okay
now the number crunching works just fine
but this is a bit weird this is weird
did you notice how weird it is this you
can factorize X plus 2 X plus 3 then you
get the solutions out and you can add
and multiply them no big deal but x
squared plus 2x plus 4 doesn't want to
be factorized right you can't think of
an easy pair of numbers that's going to
add to this and multiply to that you
can't do some factorizing but not the
kind of factorizing that'll give you
roots watch I can rewrite this I can
complete the square on the first two
terms like this that's that's a square
and since I've got 4 there and I've only
written one here I should add a 3 so you
can see this guy on the left that can be
factorized that's a perfect square is
mentioning before and so when you look
at this what does this thing look like X
plus 1 all squared that's the regular
pram that moved to the left one unit and
then plus 3 means you go up 3 years okay
so the vertex of this parabola is not at
the origin the vertex is here at
negative 1 3 and the parabola looks like
that this crab that doesn't have a roots
right that's that's weird because
apparently you could add those roots and
multiply them and get something
reasonable right so what is going on
okay
these roots don't exist how can you have
you've had or multiplied the way
well I my contention is the veterans do
exist I'm going to try and show you what
they are but to do that like this
original set of four equations we need
to add some extra stuff onto here we
need to add an extra equation